sì avventurarsi in acque inesplorate
spingersi in territori sconosciuti
superare la propria conoscenza per
spostare i propri confini sempre un po
oltre
la sete di scoperta è da sempre uno dei
tratti più distintivi e a mio parere
straordinari dello spirito umano
qualcosa che ha caratterizzato e
continua a far crescere il nostro
percorso evolutivo come specie la storia
che vorrei condividere con voi oggi
inizia a circa otto anni fa quando
affacciato alla finestra di un
grattacielo newyorkese mi ritrovavo in
una fase della mia vita in cui avevo
letteralmente perso la bussola
avevo una carriera di successo nel mondo
della moda e nonostante mi ritrovassi
all'apice paradossalmente era
precipitato al fondo in una vera e
propria crisi esistenziale quel mondo di
di luci e di eccessi quell'immagine
comune della bella vita che ci viene
propinata da film pubblicità non mi
andava più non mi sentivo soddisfatto
non mi piaceva più quello che stavo
facendo
e ancor meno quello che stava diventando
ero letteralmente arrivato al limite la
vita nella grande mela
mi stava stretta mi sentivo in gabbia
sentivo la bruciante necessità di
evadere e aveva una inarrestabile sete
di avventura è stato proprio in quel
momento che ho scoperto l'ultramaratona
attraverso ultramarathon man
la biografia di questo dean karnazes in
cui racconta la sua trasformazione da
businessman di successo a ultra laner
appunto quello che più mi colpiva era
come avesse raggiunto il successo
materiale però nonostante tutto non si
sentisse soddisfatto e la sua storia mi
toccava da vicino mi ritrovavo in ogni
sua parola
ero rimasto estremamente affascinato dal
suo salto nel vuoto aveva abbandonato la
strada vecchia per intraprendere una
tutta nuova
e aveva trovato investendo in se stesso
aveva trovando significato e profondità
nel cuore le distanze enormi in ambienti
sempre più estremi
tutti sappiamo di cosa si tratta di
quando si parla di corsa molti di voi si
chiederanno che cosa sia questo oltrre
anni come tutti sappiamo una maratona è
di 42 km e come tutti sono cresciuto con
il mito di questo evento che ha le
radici nella grecia classica
considerandola la sfida definitiva
oltre alla quale il nostro corpo
semplicemente non potesse spingersi una
vera prova di resistenza e resilienza
che porta ai limiti del proprio
potenziale fisico ora trasformato una
maratona in un'ultramaratona e la sfida
va ben oltre il fisico diventa mentale
ecco un'ultramaratona e qualsiasi
distanza che va oltre questo ami
geraghty 42 km quindi ci dai 50 km ha
100 km a 200 chilometri a volte anche di
più
e poi c'è questa leggendaria sfida di
cui parla proprio karnazes nel suo libro
la badwater 135 considerata la gara
podistica più dura del mondo ben 217 km
attraverso la valle della morte il posto
più caldo del pianeta ovviamente non
poteva che non essere corsa che nel bel
mezzo dell'estate
questo la rende non solo una sfida di
resilienza ma quasi di sopravvivenza con
temperature che arrivano a sfiorare i 55
gradi
da allora decidi decisi di lasciare
quella carriera che tanto mi stava
stretta per dettargli con tutto me
stesso a questa disciplina che in pochi
anni si è trasformata nella mia vita ad
oggi ho corso oltre 25 tra maratone in
alcuni degli ambienti più belli ea volte
inospitali che il pianeta possa offrire
probabilmente penserete tutti che sia
una pazzia è la domanda più comune è
sempre la stessa perché oppure ma chi te
lo fa fare ciò che mi affascina
maggiormente di questa disciplina
è proprio che si tratta di un concetto
assoluto stimolante che rimette in
discussione tutti gli schemi sociali e i
limiti con cui siamo cresciuti in
un'epoca in cui tutte le terre sono già
state esplorate tutte le montagne più
alte sono già state scalate ogni angolo
del globo è già stato scoperto
sembrerebbe che l'unica vera
esplorazione rimasta sia l'esplorazione
del se andare nelle profondità
dell'anima oltre qualsiasi limite fisico
penso che alla base della mia della mia
scelta ci sia stata proprio questa
necessità di entrare in contatto con me
stesso e sentirmi realmente vivo
l'eccitazione la felicità che
sperimentiamo durante una nuova
esperienza in superare gli ostacoli che
si presentano sul cammino diventano un
modo di scoprire le nostre capacità
facendoci sentire più sicuri e in un
certo modo vivi
a volte ci vuole un avventura per
mostrarci quanto sia ricco e variegato
il mondo là fuori e ci rendiamo conto
che la nostra prospettiva non è l'unica
è che c'è sempre di più da vedere sempre
di più da fare è sempre di più da
imparare
il filosofo americano sono una volta
disse molti uomini vivono una vita di
quieta disperazione e lo stile di vita
moderno ci ha dato tutto ma non ci rende
mai soddisfatti
il perché è forse dato dal fatto che
preferendo uno stile di vita ha fatto di
comfort e false sicurezze ci siamo e
stranianti da ciò che più conta la
crescita personale e il contatto con il
proprio io a volte ci vuole anche una
caduta per insegnarci quanto siamo forti
ingegnosi e coraggiosi tutti noi abbiamo
punti di forza nascosti che non sempre
conosciamo ed è solo misurandoci con noi
stessi che scopriamo le nostre capacità
delle nostre potenzialità
dopotutto se ci atteniamo semplicemente
alla nostra routine quotidiana non
fidandoci mai a trovare qualcosa di
nuovo come potremmo mai scoprire il
nostro vero valore
ogni avventura ci arricchisce e aiuta a
vedere il mondo sotto una nuova luce
chiaramente il percorso sarà sempre
pieno di ostacoli e fallimenti saranno
sempre dietro l'angolo
ma se c'è una cosa che ho imparato è che
fallimenti sono una parte fondamentale
sulla via del successo poiché ci
permettono di crescere ed imparare dai
nostri errori
ogni errore appunto comporta una nuova
scelta una nuova decisione che
certamente modella nostro destino
ed è proprio con questo spirito che ha
avuto inizio questo mio percorso nel
mondo delle ultra in questa meravigliosa
disciplina non si tratta solo di cosa si
parla di qualcosa di più andare oltre la
curiosità di scoprire cosa succede oltre
quel limite fisico quando il dolore è
così insopportabile che tutto il tuo
corpo ti supplica di fermarti c'è stato
un episodio in particolare che si è
rivelato di grandissimo insegnamento per
me
ed è proprio di questo che ti vuole
parlare oggi era l'inizio del 2016
dopo alcuni anni di esperienze oltre in
giro per il mondo
decisi di sfidare i miei limiti
ulteriormente e inviare la mia richiesta
proprio alla badwater 135 la gara più
dura del pianeta sono solo 100 gli ultrà
runner esperti provenienti da tutto il
mondo che vengono selezionati ogni anno
passano poche settimane la risposta è
l'invito a partecipare ero dentro era la
sfida che avevo sempre sognato la gara
ultrà per eccellenza volevo sperimentare
in prima persona cosa volesse dire a
ritrovarsi là fuori nelle condizioni più
estreme con solo le mie gambe e il mio
cuore attraverso un ambiente così
selvaggio e inospitale è così che il 17
luglio del 2016
mi ritrovai albergo del basil un lago
salato essicato a 90 metri sotto il
livello del mare
il punto più basso degli stati uniti con
davanti a me
217 km di strada infuocata fino al mount
whitney
il punto più alto di 48 stati contigui
il countdown e poi un grande urlo a dar
cda mentre il gruppo si snodava
rapidamente nell'immensa valle davanti a
noi la gara era iniziata alle 23 quindi
alle 11 di sera con un accogliente
temperatura di 45 gradi a seguirci un
veicolo per il team di supporto
obbligatorio per la sicurezza e per
provvedere a tutti a soddisfare tutte le
necessità alle esigenze di ogni singolo
corridore poiché ogni singolo corridore
deve abituarsi a ingerire fino a 2 litri
di acqua ogni ora dopo circa due ore di
corsa e ritrovandomi come una borraccia
vuota in mano
inizio a cercare per per il mio veicolo
tra tutti quelli che mi ronzavano
intorno cominciava a sentirmi sempre più
disidratato data alla temperatura
esorbitante ma per qualche motivo non
c'era traccia del mio team
intanto passa un chilometro poi ne passa
un altro eppure nessuno nessun nessun
segno della mia squadra
dopo quasi un ora finalmente un volto
familiare si avvicina esce dall oscurità
della notte e io completamente
disorientato e fortemente disidratato
decido di schiantarmi sul sedile
posteriore del won cercando di
recuperare riprendere le energie per
qualche motivo nel casinò della partenza
e l'oscurità della notte mi avevano
perso in questo tratto iniziale ea quel
punto il mio stomaco era già sotto sopra
la mia mente all'uci nava e il mio corpo
era già tesi bene mi disse che riti
forte mancano solo altri 180 km
nonostante questo pesante pensiero ero
determinato a finire e non importava
come a dire la verità quella avventura
era iniziata in modo ben diverso da
quello che avevo immaginato ma credo che
in un certo modo sia questo il bello
della ventura non sai mai quello che può
succedere così un passo dopo l'altro
ripresi la mia corsa che su una vera e
propria via crucis devo dire mi ero
trascinato tutta la notte poi attraverso
il calore estenuante del giorno
successivo
il punto al tramonto del secondo giorno
il mio corpo non riusciva più a muovere
un passo forti ondate di dolore mi
attraversavano la schiena quando mi resi
conto che non avevo fatto l'atp dal
giorno precedente
così i miei reni erano letteralmente in
fiamme
così decisi di fermarmi ancora una volta
una breve pausa per cercare di bere il
più possibile e poco dopo il liquido
rosso che uscì mi lascia senza parole è
preoccupato per la mia salute ero
incerto su cosa fare certe decisioni
definiscono chi siamo
mentre ero seduto in quel van immerso
nel dolore guardando gli altri corridori
che passavano iniziare a scavare dentro
di me cercando tutta la motivazione
l'ispirazione possibile per non
arrendermi poi d'improvviso mi alzai
tutto bruciato dal sole con le gambe
dure è una sensazione di un persistente
punto nel pugno nello stomaco mettendo
un passo davanti all'altro un piede
davanti all'altro
alla fine tagliare quel traguardo così
tanto agognato dopo 34 ore di costante
movimento e dopo tutto quello che avevo
passato
eros chiaramente felice di aver portato
a termine quello che mi ero prefissato
ma in tutta onestà dentro me dentro di
me
non ero assolutamente soddisfatto su un
duro colpo sia per il mio fisico che per
il mio orgoglio e mille kyle and feel it
le ferite per molto tempo
passano due anni e decido di ritentare
l'impresa e richiedendo una nuova
partecipazione è così che il 24 luglio
proprio di quest'anno mi ritrovo sulla
linea di partenza deciso a rimettermi in
discussione
ci sono molti momenti in cui mi risuona
in testa la famosa frase di steve jobs
stay hungry stay foolish
mi ricorda quanto sia importante non
sentirsi mai arrivati e che bisogna
sempre e comunque spingersi oltre questo
vuol dire continuare a provare e
riprovare anche quando tutto intorno a
noi dice che non sia possibile
quest'anno dopo 24 ore di corsa
ininterrotta sono immensamente onorato
di poter dire non solo di aver concluso
ma di aver vinto la badwater 135 un
cerchio iniziato sette anni fa con una
sua perfetta conclusione il sogno di una
vita realizzato la mia vittoria più
grande è di non essermi arreso davanti
al fallimento iniziale e di aver colto
questo ulteriore opportunità sono qui
oggi ad incoraggiarli ad avventurarvi
nell'ignoto
a rischiare ea fallire per crescere e
spingervi oltre voi stessi e oltre i
vostri limiti per vivere pienamente per
vivere veramente e solo quando viviamo
una vita intenzionale con scopo
facendo ciò che amiamo fare ed essendo
ciò che vogliamo essere che troviamo
pienezza e felicità dentro noi stessi
tutti abbiamo ambizioni ma troppo spesso
abbiamo paura di rischiare
tutti abbiamo paura di non essere
abbastanza bravi abbastanza forti
abbastanza intelligenti ci sentiamo
intrappolati dai limiti che percepiamo
perdendoci inesorabilmente nella paura
di fallire
ed è lì che tendiamo a perdere fiducia
in noi stessi ma credo sia assolutamente
necessario correre quel rischio
sbagliare rialzarsi superando quelle
paure per liberarsi e trovare se stessi
e la propria voce in ogni passo che
facciamo nell'ignoto
scopriamo la nostra forza e la nostra
perseveranza per raggiungere quei sogni
e proprio nel processo e nel processo di
crescita che realizziamo di essere tutti
molto più capaci di quello che abbiamo
sempre creduto
solo così ci evolviamo e ci spingiamo
verso una versione sempre migliore di
noi stessi un se è più cosciente più
soddisfatto è più grato
quindi in qualsiasi direzione vogliate
pre perseguire nella nostra vita nella
vostra vita
non abbiate paura di avventurarvi oltre
fate quel passo senza restrizione alcuna
e lasciate che il vostro meraviglioso
viaggio abbia inizio grazie mille